we're gonna begin with breaking news
from Syria a rare attack on us-led
coalition troops the US military says
two coalition members were killed by a
roadside bomb last night and five others
were wounded we don't know yet if
Americans were among the casualties this
attack may have happened in manbij
that's near the Syria Turkey border
where a local official says a bomb went
off last night just hours before the
bombing President Trump said the US will
end its military presence in Syria quote
very soon his comments came shortly
after the Pentagon said American troops
need to stay there
major Garrett's at the White House major
good morning good morning without a
Secretary of State and with one National
Security Advisor on the way out and
another one on the way in president
Trump yesterday began to improvise about
what comes next in Syria
say good morning the National Park
Service and in so doing caught the State
Department and Pentagon off guard
leaving advisors in both places
scrambling to figure out what the
president meant and what it might mean
for US military action there against
Isis will be coming out of Syria like
very soon
speaking in Ohio and what was billed as
a speech about infrastructure President
Trump repeatedly veered off script
appearing to make an announcement about
pulling out of Syria roughly two
thousand US troops on the ground let the
other people take care of it now as a
candidate and president mr. Trump vowed
never to make such statements we should
have never made such a sudden withdrawal
on a timetable advertised to our enemies
we no longer tell our enemies our plans
State Department officials said they
were unaware of any change in policy I
have not seen the president's comments
myself
I can say that as a general matter this
administration looks to other countries
to help out the president's comments
contradict US officials who tell CBS
News the administration has yet to
present a timeline for the u.s. to exit
Syria one official said leaving within
six months cannot be done quote
responsibly that's why I've made some
changes the president also referenced
the latest White House staff shake-up is
a stir of Veterans Affairs Secretary
David Shulkin because
I wasn't happy with the speed with which
our veterans were taken care of mr.
Trump is dealing with a shrinking inner
circle in recent days he lost his
longest-serving and most trusted
political aide hope Hicks who left her
post as White House communications
director just yesterday joining a list
of more than two dozen officials to part
ways with the Trump administration
defense secretary James Madison the
chairman the Joint Chiefs of Staff
Joseph Dunford met yesterday for the
very first time with incoming national
security adviser John Bolton madis was
overheard on camera joking to bolton
i've heard you are the devil incarnate
and i wanted to meet you
Boulton laughed and gael this is what
now passes for humor national security
style and the Trump administration hikes
thank you very much major